so first of all Jackie Chelsea Irina it
is so nice to meet you guys this season
was filled with drama there were
villains in this season as well
um and it did highlight emotional
maturity intentions like it was just so
it was the best season yet though
honestly
um so first of all I want to ask you
know what I'll start with Chelsea
um are we learning to compromise more
and how is your relationship with
kwame's Mom
oh we're totally learning to compromise
more I mean we have I have truly had a
transformation this past year and so has
Kwame I mean I think
as much as I know who I am and what I
want a relationship you know needs
compromise and finding middle ground and
growing and changing and evolving to be
better and yeah so happy that he has
brought that out and made in this
experience has as well
um my Elizabeth is Mom I have met her
and definitely Room to Grow but I'm so
happy
um to be where we are right now
awesome Jackie girl what's that what's
up from the beginning I was rooting for
you and then it just seemed like you
were going through a lot of emotional
turmoil watching it and it almost seemed
like
keep it real come on it almost seemed
like and I and I can relate to this
being addicted to
xic relationships in a way where you
need passion you need drama you need
because Marshall what seemed like the
nice guy that is it's almost harder to
be in a nice relationship after a toxic
one so all of that to say
um what were you going through and and
do you regret how you handled Marshall
in any way
I don't regret how I handled Marshall I
I don't regret how I handled him how I
handled him was the correct way and I
will continue to handle him the way I've
been handling him And in regards to the
emotional turmoil that I was having it
wasn't in regards to Marshall it's about
like my personal business like I have
like my father that I have to take care
of I have to take care of you know
family things so yeah being like in this
fantasy land for you know a short period
of time and then having to transition
back to reality that's when everything
kicked in because now I have to be
conscious of Marshall and I have to be
conscious of how he is going to feel
with you know my family and you know the
things that I'm going through so I have
to just be mindful of everybody and
that's what was really starting to get
to me for sure yeah
um where are things with you and Josh
because from the outside looking in Josh
is the toxic one
oh is it Marshall looks like the good
guy and Josh looks like the walking red
flag and it's like and we're watching
you and we're like Jackie no the whole
season so
um where are you at with Josh
well me and Mr toxic AKA Red Flag we are
together no yeah we are together we are
very strong okay
okay girl yes okay we all right breaking
news just kidding just kidding um Irena
so for you it seemed like love was not
blind for you
um was there any moment where you told
Zach like I am just not physically
attracted to you because there were
multiple moments when you're watching it
you can tell that you just you just
weren't into him
um did you guys have that conversation
at all
um the thing with me and Zach is I feel
like it wasn't about like love being
blind or not I definitely think Zach was
one of the best connections I had on the
pods and he we connected a lot about
like our past and our families and so
that's why I chose him and he did have
that character but I think seeing him I
had this like gut feeling it wasn't
anything about his appearance it was his
gut feeling of like just not feeling
this like there's so many other things
so in the pause you're talking we talked
so much about trauma and families and
all of this but then you're seeing each
other in real life and then there's
mannerisms and other people coming in
and things like that and there was just
so much there's just deep feeling in my
gut that was like this isn't this
doesn't feel right and I know Zach knew
that I didn't want to have like sex
before marriage and I I wasn't
comfortable about like before we we saw
each other I told him that like I don't
want to kiss when we see each other
because I think it's going to take me
some time but that time like never came
and I did want it to I I thought I tried
and I was like I'm gonna push for this
but I just couldn't feel it I didn't
have this like whatever what I was yeah
I basically couldn't like I just didn't
feel it in my gut and it wasn't anything
about his appearance it wasn't like I
would just say it was more like
mannerisms or everyday things like it
was just things that I was like I can't
like I don't feel comfortable on this
guy like I don't as hard from almost for
me to be myself and it sucked but I
think everything happens like for a
reason what was your initial reaction
when you found out that Zack and Bliss
got married but also Micah and Paul
didn't get married
um I'm really happy for Bliss and Zach
um I do remember telling him when we
broke up that if he wanted wanted to go
pursue her he should
um he did say that she he believes like
she didn't deserve that story
um I am happy for them I think I don't
know I haven't talked to them since
literally but I'm so happy for him like
Zach deserves the best blister deserves
the best I know she really went through
it I don't know you know how it'll be
for her watching back on everything but
like I mean Zach were meant to be
together and I think that was very
mutual like it was mutual and we didn't
like it just didn't work out we weren't
for each other and I think it's just
moving forward it's like I'm yeah I'm
happy for them and I hope they're doing
great
um and for Paul and Micah I definitely
thought I had no idea to be honest
because I didn't talk to her during
filming we were really good friends
we're best friends now but
um on Saturday didn't work out for them
I guess but I honestly everything again
it's like everything happens for a
reason but I was also really surprised
okay so you might date Paul all right
great
I have not reached out to him and I have
not said anything he is not the agenda
he's not on my agenda I want to clear
that up that I would never make a move
towards Paul I think would have had a
lot of alcohol I might have done some
flirting but that wasn't who I am as a
person and I would like that's why I
went up to Micah right away and said hey
I told the producer like I said I had
feelings for Paul but it wasn't the
sense that I want to go pursue him it
was in the sense of like hey I I have
this connection easily with him and I
want to have that with my husband and I
did it with Zach so I would never go
after him whatever I said in the pool
was not who I am as a person and it was
really embarrassing on my character and
that's not who I am and I just want to
make that really clear awesome thank you
ladies I really appreciate your time and
I can't wait for you guys to watch the
season there's crazy moments but there's
also amazing moments too so
um have a good day thank you